[Music]
on this Sunday night agonizing
anniversary the humanitarian toll after
3 months of conflict in the Middle East
this is a conflict that could easily
metastasize as weapons of war continue
to take innocent lives concerns of a
wider conflict take center stage in
Cutter Iran's regime has a long history
of trying to intimidate um members of
the diaspora accusations Iran is ramping
up its campaign to silence Iranian
Canadians on a tragic
anniversary this weekend blast of winter
too little too late concerns for the
coming year after a hot and dry
2023 we had to fight for 12 years to
become gender equal and how a Canadian
Olympic canoeist and her dad are
smashing ceilings in
sports global national with baren Asser
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us to today marks 3 months of
bloody attacks in Gaza after hamas's
strike on October 7th that according to
the Israeli government killed 1,00
people and kidnapped an estimated 240
others that same day Israel declared war
against Hamas before launching its
allout assault since then life and
security on both sides of this conflict
has been upended for Israelis the fear
of waking up to militants for gazin the
reality of losing family members as they
sleep the world's underlying worry right
now 3 months in that this war could
spread the US Secretary of State arrived
in the Middle East today to warn
countries in the region that this
conflict could easily escalate Anthony
blinkin says most people in the Middle
East want peace and too many people in
Gaza have died and a warning you might
find our coverage tonight disturbing
according to the Hamas run Health
Ministry almost 23,000 people have been
killed since the War Began the United
Nations says 2third or some 70% of those
killed in Gaza are women and children
according to UNICEF Gaza has become a
graveyard for more than 5,000 children
doctors without borderers says more than
a hundred children are being killed each
day the United Nations also says 85% of
the Palestinian territory's population
is now displaced and that cases of
disease are rapidly rising and nutrition
is plummeting Israel will face the
international court of justice this week
on accusations it's committing genocide
in Gaza which Israel rejects but as
Redmond Shannon reports Israel still
says it will not stop until Hamas is
totally
eliminated 75-year-old Hashim Abul Naga
says he's the only person left of his
entire family after an air strike on
Rafa in southern
[Music]
Gaza there are 33 people in the rubble
including women and children he says
adding that no one in his family was a
militant is this blink's gift to us on
his visit he asks in reference to US
military support for Israel far too many
Palestinians innocent Palestinians have
already been killed US Secretary of
State Anthony blinkin is in the Middle
East for the fourth time since October
7th speaking with leaders in Jordan and
later cater holding talks on the
regional spread of the conflict hostage
negotiations and the fate of gazin We
are continuing uh our discussions with
the parties and trying to uh achieve as
soon as possible an agreement that can
bring u a Seas fire and humanitarian uh
relief and the release of of the
hostages we continue to raise with
Israel the need to do everything
possible to facilitate the provision of
humanitarian Aid to Gaza we reject the
statements by some Israeli ministers and
lawmakers calling for a resettlement of
Palestinians outside of
Gaza these statements are irresponsible
they're inflammatory the US remains
Israel's biggest Ally and blink heads
there this week treading a diplomatic
tight
rope Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu says he won't stop the
military campaign until Hamas has been
eliminated and all hostages are freed
but Hamas insists the bombing must stop
for more hostages to be released two of
the latest victims of those Israeli
strikes are more journalists one of them
Hamza aladu the son of Al jazer reporter
whale aladu in October whale's wife two
other children and a grandson were
killed in another air
strike what has my family done to Israel
he asks the committee to protect
journalists says 79 journalists and
media workers have been killed in this
war Redman Channon Global News
London and while Innocents continue to
be killed in Gaza there has been a flare
up in Bloodshed in the West Bank an
Israeli air strike early this morning
killed six Palestinians in Janine
according to the Palestinian health
authority Israel police say one of its
officers was killed in the city when her
vehicle was hit by an explosive and
according to the Israeli Defense Force
and Israeli civilian was shot dead in
the rala
area uh the
keeper back here in Canada Pro
Palestinian protesters drown out Toronto
mayor Olivia Chow's remarks during the
city's annual mayor skate party the
demonstrators called for freedom for
Palestinians and an end to the violence
happening in Gaza demanding a ceasefire
but they largely stayed on the sidelines
during the
event in Ukraine the country endured yet
another round of air strikes from Russia
overnight officials say at least 11
people were killed by a Russian missile
strike including five children in the
Ukraine controlled part of the dones
region in the city of nepro a dozen
people were injured from a drone attack
Ukraine's Air Force says Russia launched
28 attack drones and three cruise
missiles overnight but they say air
defense systems shot down all of the
drones there are more flight disruptions
in the US today after that frightening
ordeal on an Alaska Airlines flight the
airline again grounded all of its mowing
737 Max n jetliners after Federal
officials in the US indicated further
maintenance might be required the FAA
ordered them grounded after an Alaska
Airlines flight had a portion of its
fuselage blown out shortly after takeoff
from Portland on Friday the plane landed
safely with no serious injuries Alaska
had returned 18 of its 65 Max NES to
service after the initially passed
inspection the FAA says 170 1 Boeing Max
9 Airplanes will remain grounded until
they are all deemed safe in British
Columbia one person has been found dead
after a helicopter crash in the
province's mountainous interior RCMP say
the private helicopter was traveling
from Calgary to syc on Friday evening
when they were alerted of a ping from an
emergency locator transmitter about 18
kilometers east of Revelstoke after two
days of searching rescue crews found the
wreckage in Glacier National Park the
cause that the crash is under
investigation the victim was the sole
occupant of the
helicopter across Canada today winter
has finally arrived from blizzards to
deep freezes to snow accumulation much
of the country is finally getting a real
taste of the Season Abigail Bean looks
at what we can all expect in the months
to
come people in the nation's capital woke
up to the first serious snowfall of the
Season finally a respectable sprinkling
they told me Canada is snow sow way and
when I I came here I I found nothing so
where is snow it's joke no but nownow
it's good I'm so excited I'm really
happy uh we got a few centimeters
overnight and uh some more coming today
and winter has been slow to show up in
most of Canada Sunday's map shows a
different story with weather warnings
and statements right across the country
from a blizzard warning in Black tickled
newfinland to a significant snowfall
expected on BC's Sunshine Coast the
Prairies will see the coldest
temperatures this week a piece of the
polar vortex the Arctic Aira that's
usually over the North Pole is going to
shift over Saskatchewan Manitoba and
Alberta places like Calgary are looking
at daytime highs struggling to get out
to the minus 30s overnight lows in the
mid-30s and early morning wind chills
potentially pushing toward Theus 50 the
city of Winnipeg warning people to stay
safe with the windchill making it feel
as cold Asus 27 Sunday night for many a
winter burst is welcome news like this
qualifying event at an Edmonton Ski Hill
for the Alberta and Arctic Winter
Games we've had a postpone a few events
um we're hoping that we can run them
maybe later on in the season uh we're
hoping for some more snow the big
question for people who live in Ottawa
and tourists alike when will we be able
to skate on the canal last time for the
first time in its history the canal was
closed all season due to warm weather
crews are already working to get it open
but it hasn't been cold enough we need
about 2 weeks at at least - 10 for save
ice kind of symbolic of the changing of
winter and the fact that we're on track
for it not to be opening anytime soon
but the second year in a row is is
pretty depressing I'd rather you know be
pleasantly surprised than you know have
the hopes crushed again while other
parts of Canada are still waiting for
winter salt trucks are out in BC
prepping for a snowy and rainy blast as
for the rest of the winter well February
is the real wild card here we're not
really seeing any strong Trend either
way I think it'll likely be closer to
seasonal maybe slightly warmer than
normal but pull out the parkas for now
with a colder than normal January
Abigail Bean Global News
Ottawa the snow is a welcome sight to
cross the Prairies as many regions
continue to battle historic droughts
20123 was hot and dry and the Outlook is
no better for 2024 as Heather yor West
explains the situation is so bad that
the Alberta Government is already
warning communities and Industry to plan
for potential water shortages in the
month
ahead it's a blast of winter but across
Southern Alberta this January snowfall
is likely too little and too late we
know snow is how we got into trouble
last year with the drought uh the snow
packs were below normal and then they
melted early well this year they're
below what they were last year while
much of the country is experiencing
drought conditions right now the
situation is most serious across parts
of the Northwest Territories and the
southern prairies setting the stage for
some big problems around the
availability of water in a year ahead
just before the holidays we reached out
to uh municipalities across the province
uh because we really wanted to make sure
that they were putting plans in place
last spring Calgary enacted restrictions
on water use for the first time in the
city's history but with Reservoir levels
low and the alal weather pressure still
in play many forecasters believe this
Summer's drought could be even more
severe Le bridge is uh very very
concerned about being to able to supply
drinking water to its residents uh next
over this year and uh many rural
communities that rely on small surface
water ponds are in dire trouble it's a
problem for industry too 50% of
Alberta's water is allocated to farming
but the region is also a major food
processing Hub food processing is quite
intensive and it requires a lot of water
if you don't have any water you have to
cut back on production and that's the
last that's the last thing you want to
do as a business because production Cuts
would see food prices climb it's not as
if we're just in some bad luck I think
there's been a fundamental change to our
climate with warmer temperatures there's
greater demand for that water especially
if we see a wildfire season as bad as
2023 water is a critical resource and
the lack of it could be one of the
biggest challenges facing Western
Canadians this year Heather U West
Global News Calgary
The Fallout from Nova scotia's flooding
disaster coming up why the province's
program to help is falling far
short it was last July when flash floods
left parts of Nova Scotia unrecognizable
and though it's already 2024 some
residents are still waiting for much
needed help a couple is Raising
questions about the province's disaster
financial assistance program as Vanessa
Wright reports they have yet to receive
a single scent despite applying months
ago before I do anything after
everything is done it'll be clean again
for David and claudet Oxford coming home
doesn't have the same feel or look as it
once did it's been undergoing repairs
for the better part of 3 months he was
just one of the many homes to suffer
damage from flash floods in Nova Scotia
last July but this happened so fast this
was a this was a flood that went from
zero water in the basement to 7 ft of
water in the basement in under half an
hour the water engulfing furniture
kitchen items and everything in their
basement flushing away 40 years of
memories in its wake down the basement
you could poke your finger in the wall
it was saturated with water so bad um
and the mold was growing on the Walls
Within 2 to 3 days down there also the
oxfords applied for the province's
disaster financial assistance program
last October they say since then someone
did come to their Bedford home to assess
the damage but as far as financial
assistance they have yet to see a dime
I'm a little surprised I haven't had
something come back in writing or a
letter or an email or something just to
say we've received your claim it looks
like you qualify and over time you don't
even have to give me a date but over the
next year or the next six months uh a
resolution or whatever will be made in a
statement to Global News Nova scotia's
emergency management office says at this
time more than 1,600 applications have
been received through the July 2023
floods DFA program and more than $4.5
million in payments have been issued she
adds the remaining applications are in
various stages of processing which can
take several months it's difficult for
people to move on with their lives if
they don't have any idea you know a is
the government going to help them and be
how much does that entail now despite
paying more than $90,000 in repairs out
of out of pocket the oxfords say they
still consider themselves to be the
lucky ones that's compared to the other
35 households along the street who saw
similar damages but haven't been able to
pay for repairs as quickly at the end of
the day we were able to do it I I was
able to do it I feel that people who
weren't able to do it it's a whole
different discussion one that he hopes
comes soon for those not as fortunate as
them Vanessa Wright Global News Bedford
Nova Scotia
ahead why Iran is Banning a Canadian
activist's mother from leaving the
[Music]
country across the country tonight there
are vigils marking the fourth
anniversary of the Downing of flight
ps752 in Iran all to remember the 176
people on board who lost their lives in
including many Canadians when the
Ukrainian passenger plane was mistakenly
shot down by Iran's Islamic
revolutionary guard Corp over
Tran 55 Canadians and 30 permanent
residents were among those killed in the
tragedy and while victim's families
still grapple with Sor four years later
the Iranian regime is ramping up its
campaign to silence dissidents abroad
nagar moah
reports
you don't have to speak farsy to
understand the pain in this mother's
voice the thought of never seeing you
again she says is driving me crazy
Canadian activist hmed is smun says his
mother tan shamsu laahi has been banned
from leaving Iran for at least 6 months
she she was in distress I I have heard
that she was shivering when she heard
the news shamahi was stopped at Ton's
airport as seen here on her way to
Canada to be with ismile Yun to Mark the
4-year anniversary of his wife and
daughter's
deaths both killed when Iran's Islamic
revolutionary guard Corps shot down
their flight with two surfac to- a
missiles Canada must stand for justice
is Yun believes the ban is a form of
Revenge for his activism and following
his calls for action after a former
senior minister of the regime was seen
vacationing in Canada it's Republic
always has punished U like Iranian
activists out of Iran by by taking their
families as a hostage Global Affairs
Canada posted on X that it is deeply
concerned about the intimidation of
family members of victims of flight
ps752 we appreciate that but this is not
enough Iran's regime has a long history
of trying to intimidate U members of the
diaspora human rights lawyer K shatu
says accounts like this are not unusual
with threats from the regime even on
Canadian soil a recent Global News
investigation uncovered reports of
hundreds of regime linked Associates
living in Canada and instead of giving
him Justice the Iranian regime um is now
harassing other members of his family
and putting him under threat it really
speaks to how Despicable and evil the
Iranian regime is it was important to
have my mom uh in my side while regime
linked insiders are living in Canada
ison's mother can't even leave Iran
denied access to her son at a time when
he needs her the
most Nar mosah Global News
Vancouver next the Calgary Olympic
family smashing gender barriers in
[Music]
sports a Calgary Olympic canoeist who
broke gender barriers in her sport is
speaking out about the importance of
fighting for what you believe in as
Carolyn Curry de Castillo reports
Olympian Haley Daniels comes from an
athletic family who shares stories of
the struggle to be
accepted as an athlete Haley Daniels
knows the hard work it takes to win but
in her case she had to fight just to
compete we had to fight for 12 years to
become gender equal when Haley competed
at the Summer Olympics in Tokyo in 2021
she made history women's canoe kayak
events had previously been excluded from
the games that year the sport made its
debut
it was hard to go to training some days
when you had no idea if your dream will
ever actually come to fruition you have
to believe in a cause even when a lot of
people don't believe in it this weekend
Haley was speaking at the female sports
Summit in Calgary we can show the growth
and the opportunity that's come because
of courageous women she says there's
been some major strides in women's
sports but change is still needed when
it comes to equal pay and sponsorship
according to the international Olympic
Committee uh everything is gender equal
but uh just because there's gender
equality in terms of representation on
the field does not mean that that is
equality in terms of how much
sponsorship dollars there are her dad
Kimberly Daniels was at the Tokyo games
too as the first openly transgender
Olympic judge my dad lived uh the
majority of her life uh as someone who
she did not feel comfortable being and
it took her until 65 years old to come
out authentically and so uh if you can
do that earlier in your life it's a lot
easier Haley describes sport is still
having an exclusive element where
everything is based on gender lines
sport it's there's a male category and a
female category and there is no it's
black and white there is no uh other
category both Haley and her dad are
encouraging others to have open
conversations about gender diversity in
sport she says change takes time but her
family's struggles have proved that it
happens there is a an amazing accepting
community of people now and there's a
lot less
naysayers uh but she's going to have a
challenge but she also has to know
there's Amazing Allies I'm her Ally I
can be there for her um and there's
people that believe in her or him or
they Carol and Curry de Castillo Global
News and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm faren AER and on behalf
of our whole crew here I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
Sunday evening with us tonight's here
Canada is Saskatoon where the city's
Police Service is celebrating a very
special retirement Brian a 10-year-old
German Shepherd has spent the last eight
years sniffing out evidence tracking
people down and apprehending suspects as
a police service dog he now gets to
spend most of his days going for walks
playing Fetch and chilling by the lake
Donna will be back with you tomorrow
until next time take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good
night
[Music]